after the normal world you have the what
the moment the WTF moment and that
is the essence of the comic premise a
comic premise is and is the idea that
something impossible or improbable
happens impossible in the sense of a man
living the same day over and over again
that's impossible improbable that a
somewhat out of shape not to physical
analysts could be put out into the field
and do the daring do that a James Bond
would that's not impossible but it isn't
probable and so the comic premises
revolve around the thought that this
impossible or improbable moment happens
and it asks the question well what would
happen then and the best comedies then
develop that premise through character
Paul Feig talks about how he wrote the
script for spy focusing not on what
funny things he could do but what comic
moments would come out of character of
simply putting Melissa McCarthy's
character in these perilous situations
and then seeing how she would cope how
she would grow how she would become not
not only a better person but a more
fully realized person of who she is
so after you have the WTF WTF moment you
have the what we have what we call the
reaction now in most comedies when the
character is faced with a life changing
life altering impossible situation most
characters desperately try to claw back
to the normal world now remember in the
normal world your characters are
misshapen they're your your your
protagonists are not who they want to be
or need to be but they don't know it
they're unaware of it they're they're
like they turn themselves into a pretzel
to try to convince themselves that
they're having a happy life that their
life is okay and when the comic premise
occurs that's all taken away from them
the rug is literally pulled out from
under their feet so in in most reaction
sections there's a mother there's a
large part of the action that's denial
the the characters desperately trying to
go back to who they were the way they
were before this occurred in Tropic
Thunder for instance the WTF moment is
Steve Coogan the director has taken
Robert Downey jr. and Ben Stiller and
all these other actors out into the the
country out into the jungle because
they're making a vietnam-era movie and
he wants them to experience the country
you know ma'am the country and he
accidentally steps on a landmine and
blows himself up and while some of the
actors especially Jay Baruchel kind of
thinks well this is not this isn't part
of the movie this is not right
Ben Stiller the protagonist of the movie
is convinced that it's simply part of
the directors plan and he keeps on
trying to go along and keep filming this
this movie this Vietnam era movie so he
is in denial that this has happened in
Groundhog Day
Bill Murray spends the the first day
that he has relived in denial he he says
have we lived this is it still
groundhogs day it's only until the third
day when he finally starts to then
figure out what's happening and how he
can deal with it so the first part of
reaction is usually denial but the
second part of reaction is starting to
cope with the new situation but without
any character development or or
personality development or personality
change
for instance Bill Murray in Groundhog
Day
is kind of a jerk so when he realizes
that whatever he does will have no
consequence for him he still is a jerk
he figures out that if he can go talk to
a girl and get some information from her
he can come back the next day he'll
remember all the conversation but she
won't and he can pick her up and have
sex with her and and there thereby he
has sex with all the women in
Punxsutawney after a time so so you can
see that he's dealing with the situation
but really without any character growth
for a Melissa McCarthy her reaction is
both pain and sorrow because she loved
Jude Law but it's also anger and a sense
of that she has to avenge his death Jude
Law gave her this terrible piece of
jewelry that he put on a lanyard a crazy
cupcake that he gave to Melissa McCarthy
and of course it's it's it's a terrible
idea to give that to a girl who is in
love with you but but it becomes very
important symbolic touchstones tangible
touchstone is very important in in film
because you can say a lot with a little
so so at his funeral or or the memorial
service for him at the CIA you can see
Melissa McCarthy taking out the crazy
cupcake ceramic kind of touching it and
you could tell that she's trying to hold
on to Bradley Cooper Bradley find played
by Jude Law and then in another scene at
the CIA when they realized that
everybody's covers been blown and
there's this nuclear bomb on the loose
but none of her regular spies like Jason
Statham's Ford can go after it
Melissa McCarthy takes out the crazy
cupcake holds on to it and and quite out
of character jumps out and says I can go
they don't know me so that's her
reaction her
reaction is is that even though she's
scared and even though she really
doesn't have any faith in herself she
still is because of her great love for
for Bradley fine for Jude Law she's
still going to do it so so reaction is
the moment when characters are still
trying to deal with this impossible or
improbable set of circumstances that
they're now trying to deal with and what
happens in this sequence is your your
characters are given simple tasks and
missions to try to get to where they're
going to go or or do what they're going
to do for Melissa McCarthy and spy first
she sent to Paris and all she has to do
is go into an office and spy on this bad
guy who's going to lead her to other bad
guys who are going to lead her to the
nuclear bomb that's simple
she doesn't have to become a super spy
to do that but because they're on to her
and because they blown up the office
building where she was supposed to be
one thing leads to another and there's a
series of discreet missions or or tasks
that she felt that she follows one after
the other that lead her on the path to
trying to recover the bomb get the bad
guys and and then avenge her love Jude
Law and all the while she's doing this
without her realizing it she's changing
because what happens in in accommodate
and you can argue in almost any movie
but especially in comedies because
you're ten you're starting with
characters who are more than flawed
they're broken there they are something
wrong with them you can absolutely say
there's something wrong with Ben Stiller
in Tropic Thunder because he's an idiot
there's something wrong with Bill Murray
in Groundhog Day
he's a jerk there's something wrong with
Susan
Cooper Melissa McCarthy inspired because
she's got no confidence she she has no
sense of who she is and because of this
impossible situation that they're now
going to have to react to the characters
are transformed in in romantic comedy
it's love that transforms a character
you know psychiatrists will tell you
that you know if you marry a jerk 30
years later you have an older fatter
bald or jerk but in romantic comedies
love is a magical power that is
transformative it transforms people in
Groundhog Day transforms Bill Murray
from a jerk into a really good guy he
has to live through several lifetimes to
get to be able to do that but still for
Melissa McCarthy and spy
what's transformative is even though
she's not aware of it she's being able
to come up with new powers new skills
and in reaction is the part of the movie
in which new skills that had been hinted
at in in the normal world new skills
start to appear
you